All the best stuff happens in the dark.
There's dancing and music in the dark.
People are younger and better-looking in the dark.
See?
Bowling is less sad in the dark.
Your most valuable blackmail material will happen in the dark.
People wear their most stylish and glamorous clothes in the dark.
Food becomes more expensive and romantic in the dark.
People gain an irrational sense of invincibility in the dark.
And if you're well below average-looking,...
...your only chance of kissing an attractive person is...
...yep, in the dark.
So if all this good stuff happens in the dark,...
...wouldn't you want a camera that can capture things in the dark?
The new Galaxy S7 Edge with low-light camera.